let's go uh we really are taking a tour
of the world today i want to go next to
eric
from toronto uh our friendly neighbors
to the north eric you can go ahead
and unmute and i would love to hear
what's on your mind holy crap
well first i wasn't expecting to talk to
you but uh
hopefully you're doing well i enjoy your
content well listen eric when i woke up
this morning i didn't expect to be
talking to you either so we're both in
the same situation
well after watching the debate last
night i was watching your live stream
oh my god just horrified yeah
i um
i i don't know if there's a winner to
this debate to be honest and it didn't
sway anyone either way
it's just it's just unfortunate like
people are brainwashed into believing
trump it's just
crazy and i can't imagine like
thinking that he's the choice to pick
for this election it's just oh my god
i tend to agree with you that the debate
so if you
if you follow somebody who predicts
elections
with a qualitative rubric like alan
lichtman
he doesn't think debates make any
difference at all and i i tend to agree
in terms of the math of it the the only
thing is
a very small margin in a few states
could flip the election
so while i don't think the debates will
move
the polling significantly i do recognize
that you know if just one percent of the
population
in wisconsin found trump to be a
petulant child and biden to seem like an
adult
that one percent could actually swing
wisconsin you know you understand what
i'm saying yeah
i am and another thing i want to bring
up while i'm here is i i really do hope
that moderating gets better like
i remember what you were saying like why
aren't they cutting the mics
well they don't have the mechanism the
parties the parties would have to agree
to that
to give the moderator that power and of
course trump in particular never would
uh yeah and it's upsetting though i mean
you can just see how broken it all is
i'm just talking with my co-worker here
i'm working at the same time
it's just like we're both just talking
like how can they not mute the mics like
what kind of process is this if the
trump disputes
garble over yeah i mean like not that
biden was like anything to write home
about either like you said but
no like i said yesterday biden had four
to five strong answers in particular his
last answer he had about
three zingers and he had five or six
weak moments where he seemed uh unable
to kind of sequentially lay out a vision
and i think that those are the moments
that trump is going to fixate on
yeah every time biden stuttered i i my
heart sank a little bit but
you know what i think he at least didn't
face plant right that's
that's the important thing and um yeah
you know i'm just happy to check in with
you that's all i really had to say um
also uh hello pat and uh you know thanks
for taking my call
all right thank you very much we're
gonna uh say goodbye to eric from
toronto and pat you can make a note that
people have said hello and that's a
beautiful thing we're going to go to a
very brief break if you're
holding on don't go anywhere because
we're going right back to the calls
momentarily
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time
check out one of my all-time favorite
apps
called blinkist blinkist lets you
consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect if you don't have
enough time
to do all the reading you want to do or
if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video